as many people have observed of the
thousands of people that streamed into
the capital
on wednesday's rights very few have been
arrested on the order
of 50 or 60 people despite the fact that
five people have now lost their lives
including one capital police person
and on top of that it's a national
security nightmare the
computers of the members of congress
were accessed
files may have been stolen and there's
no good reason as to why these people
weren't arrested and detained
instead of just letting them out
scot-free well the good news is there's
no reason that stops the fbi or the
department of justice from arresting
these people
after the fact it's an evidentiary issue
it's not a legal impediment it's not
like
if you flee a crime scene you're
suddenly absolved of the crime it's just
an evidentiary matter of going through
all of the social media posts and
luckily these people were not afraid to
videotape themselves and
just finding the guilty parties it can
happen after the fact
days weeks months or even years later
but anyway i'll see you in court and if
you were there on wednesday
maybe literally